I'm a 17-year old I'm a blue belt in
jujitsu which I received a few days
after my 16th birthday and I have
ambitions of pursuing jujitsu
professionally and competing to the
highest level possible of course this
requires discipline and commitment so
during the school term I trained you to
Monday through Saturday and I wait train
on Friday and Sunday and when I have
time off school I trained you two three
times a day however due to my commitment
to this and my refusal to prioritize the
other things over this I feel I'm
missing out on the social opportunities
of this part of my life I miss parties
and social events in order to strange
Jitsu and wait train because I know that
I should have the discipline to do so
however I feel lonely and isolated
because of it is this just weakness or
should I make the occasional exception
for a social event once again love the
work you do you and echo do and said
it's helped me immensely thanks from the
UK all right that UK um first of all
it's just okay the hard core here's a
couple hard core answers the hard core
Nets number what's your schedule like
right are you wasting any time have you
have you maximum maximize the hours you
can get out of a day or are you spending
time doing other things that you
shouldn't be doing that being said it
sounds like you're getting after it
pretty hard which means you're probably
pretty efficient and if you're if you're
not wasting a bunch of time and you're
not doing a bunch of things that are
non-productive and you're feeling lonely
and isolated then guess what you're
going too far you don't you should not
be feeling lonely and isolated that's
not good you need to relax especially
because if you're training that much
you're likely overtraining so broadly
speaking now broadly speaking training
should be enjoyable okay this doesn't
mean that you're gonna love it every day
and I talk about that all the time it
doesn't mean every day you wake up and
you're all you know smile from one ear
to the other year because you're so
happy you got to go do you know squats
and deadlifts like no that doesn't
happen but
broadly the way it makes you feel the
way jiu-jitsu makes you feel should make
it the other times when you go on the
Jitsu mat and you get spanked and you
get ground out and you get tapped out
and you feel like junk
yes that's gonna happen but again
broadly how does Jesus you make you feel
it makes you feel good you should enjoy
it to some extent right and you should
not be getting burnt out and I think
that's the most important thing is that
you shouldn't be getting burnt out on
jujitsu on working out and and this is
this is important especially for your
seventeen years old
there is more to life than jujitsu and
physical fitness right there's more -
there's more - there's more to doing
well in life than just jujitsu and
physical fitness so a couple things if
you can't if you can't like communicate
with people effectively that's a real
problem in any environment mmm
right and if you're isolating yourself
from other people and you're not you're
not learning how to interact with other
human beings in a social environment
that's not good and it's not only it's
not only that it's it's not only that
it's just not good for you because yes
you as a person you need to be
well-rounded you need to be yes you need
to be strong you need to be capable from
a fighting perspective but you also need
to be smart you need to be articulate
you need to be quick-witted and those
things are mandatory skills in life I
mean if you're a black belt in jujitsu
and you're a white belt in communicating
with other human beings that's not going
to be a good situation for you and the
other thing is the better you are the
more well-rounded you are in all these
other aspects life those things will
actually make you better at Jiu Jitsu -
because you'll be able to read people
you'll be able to deal with
confrontation you'll be able to
understand other people's motivations
and all those things come from
interacting with other human beings so I
get it I get the massive commitment and
that is what it takes like if you want
to compete at the highest level
I'm telling you yes you have to live
breathe and eat jiu-jitsu you have to
live breathe and eat conditioning and
that being said if that's all you live
breathe and eat that's gonna make you
less apt to be a champion then if you
make yourself a little bit more
well-rounded in some of these other
aspects so do keep training hard 17 year
old blue belt from UK keep training hard
go out occasionally hang out with some
people have a good time and that by no
means means get hammered every day you
know at all not at all
yeah yeah yeah that's social aspect man
that's like that's it seems like a lot
of times especially when you're training
are you doing something that's kind of
directly or can be viewed as like
directly opposite of a social thing you
know when you think socially you think
all you guys are just slacking going to
the bar cruising at the beach whatever
well while we're over your training kind
of thing right just like just like
people say oh you're sleeping on the
couch you know what are you lazy sleep
on the couch well I don't know maybe
they need rest you know or me there's
there's there's use in sleep seems like
that was a that was a little maybe kind
of a glimpse into the echo Charles world
right there maybe not like I sleep on
the couch maybe I need rest
maybe I'm recovering from the work I'm
saying there's two parts of it you know
there's that and so in people give it a
bad rap I think specially like you know
how like you know you hear these you
know motivational gurus grind you all
sleep when I'm dead you know that kind
of thing right yeah I say that you said
it not me but hey all right so the and
I'm not saying that you know that's dumb
or nothing like that I'm jaded I'm
saying that it produces a certain
message that can be interpreted in a way
that might not be the most beneficial
well I'm sure I think this just I'm glad
that he asked this question because he's
taking the attitude of like okay I'm
gonna sleep when I'm dead
and I'm gonna I'm gonna hang out with
all
human beings after I'm a world champion
and again do you need to be possessed to
be a world champion yes you do but all
I'm saying is part of the things that
will make you be a better well-rounded
person and the more well-rounded you are
the better you're gonna perform yeah you
know you're gonna learn how to deal with
anxiety you're gonna learn how to deal
with people you're gonna learn how to
look at someone else's situation look in
their eyes and be like okay this guy's
stressed out or this guy's panicking or
this guy you know you learn those things
from interacting with other people
that's gonna make you a better
competitor you're gonna learn more about
yourself that's gonna make you a better
competitor yeah and you're gonna be if
you if you relax now what you don't want
to do is go so far in the other
direction where you where you'd show up
to a competition you don't feel like
you've prepared as much as you could
yeah but that what does that do you go
too far in the other direction now you
over trained yeah so you got to find a
little bit of it sounds like you're a
little bit off balance especially
because you're feeling like the words
that kind of keep me off the most in
this was what was it lonely and isolated
that's what kind of key if you said
everything else here and then you were
like am i over training I would have
said nah man you're getting after a good
job but then when you say look I feel
lonely and isolated you don't want to
feel lonely and isolated like and that's
another thing when I change it's ooh
that's kind of where I hang out like I
don't interact with people normally it's
a social thing we might not even talk we
might not even say one word other than
do you want a role and then we train and
that's sort of my social activity of
hanging around with other people and I
don't feel I leave the gym and I feel
like I hung out with a lot of people I
didn't say anything to him mmm-hmm but
if you feel lonely and isolated that's
not good that's getting to you that
means your mind is starting to be worn
down from this don't let it get worn
down it's gonna refuel you to go out
it's gonna I watch this watch this if
you're feeling lonely and isolated your
workout that day is like a nine if you
feel like like hey I'm having a good
life I'm I'm filled with energy I like
hanging out I just you know had a good
time with this girl last night and now
I'm going to Train it's like oh okay
guess what that's workouts in 9.7 you
get a better training because you had a
good time yeah
so yeah I don't like the I don't like
the fact that he says he's lonely and
isolated that's not good
and uh again this is just a dichotomy
because then you get someone that says
okay well chocolate should go out and
you don't have party you know party
party with the ladies and then and help
my work up yeah it'll help my work out
and then well you know maybe if I only
work out three times a week and I spend
most of my time partying I'll be just
I'll get workouts level 11 no you want
so yeah man make some exceptions to your
discipline and go enjoy the company of
some other people grow a little bit as a
person become a better human compete
better train harder that's it agree man
this is a concept that I think is if you
can kind of incorporate or understand
this concept in you know when you're
working hard at something so when I was
young when I first started lifting
weights first started mono 15 or what
however old so you know you know how
when you lift weights and you get that
little pump right
to me I thought that that's literally my
muscles growing you know like it I
didn't know how it all worked out so I
can hang my mouth I can see the growth
already so all I got to do is lift every
single day and watch out quick you know
cuz most people they won't work as hard
as me cuz all just because I like doing
it I like to pump whatever so I would do
we remember the guy my friend I
mentioned Eric masters pilot in the Air
Force yes
so he he had blown the one he always had
the soda above them I anyway so I'd lift
with him and his dad would invite me and
my brother over will lift and he started
off with banshan you know this stuff so
we go lift and I'm like they feel all
pumped so now when I when we trans kind
of went into I wanna say like varsity
football don't know anyway we started
lifting in the weight room at the high
school so I would do the same thing
every single day every single day every
single day and my friend was like this
other guy I know he goes hey you are you
benching every single day it was like
yeah and he was like well your muscles
aren't gonna grow I was like what are
you talking about of course they do they
grow everything
like I feel it even though you don't
know how it works it's like you don't
when you lift they don't grow they
actually get torn they get like almost
like a little micro injury that's how it
works and then when you rest and when
you sleep and when you eat then they
grow I was like what and he did it still
didn't make sense so I was like okay I
guess you know he's like you ever heard
you know when that the soreness you know
when you get the soreness so I was like
yeah he was like that's like it like
hurt like kind of injured or whatever
and then it has to heal up and when it
heals up it heals up bigger okay it's
like so you can't bend to every day
otherwise it'll just like it'll just
won't grow it always be damaged I was
like all make sense
so that rest in between workouts mmm
it's kind of important given Michael
Grosso muscles you see I'm saying
where this kind of thing works like all
go all go no rest right you need that
rest to grow literally mm-hmm and that
goes for anything truth